hi it's alvin welcome to the making it
big
season three marathon got a lot of fun
episodes in this video for you guys
and i thought i'd give you guys some
insider tips some fun facts about each
episode to look forward to
exciting news is that season four is
coming out soon we have a lot of fun
stuff a lot of collabs a lot of great
guests
some people that you might recognize
some people that you might know
from other channels so i'm excited for
the season
thank you guys for the support and
excited to show you guys what we made so
starting off with the giant cheesecake
there is a moment in the video where you
can see
me pouring all that batter when we get
to that part
it was so heavy that one time
to actually get it in i actually had to
cut get some help
because the batter was so heavy and
thick that it would
barely make it into the container and i
was so scared that it was gonna spill
that i don't want to risk it so big
thank you to the culinary team but yeah
watch out for the part where
pouring the batter because that part is
really tricky welcome back to tasty's
making a big the show
where we make giant versions of some of
america's most beloved foods we're in a
different time different place different
circumstances but tasty's love for giant
food hasn't changed so today we're gonna
be making a
giant cheesecake why i like cheesecake
enough talking let's get started
so the first thing that we're going to
do is the crust i have
120 graham crackers and then i'm going
to
process it and we go
[Music]
i like graham crackers a lot all right
let's go crush them
all right one back down 10 000 more to
go
[Music]
all right i think we're done it's like
sand
thank you for your hard work today
you've been a great service back to the
equipment room with you
now it's time to melt seven sticks of
butter
it barely fits in the pot
[Music]
i've been babies hitting this butter
quite a while now i don't even want to
think about how many calories are in
here
let me know in the comments
some sugar probably a lot of sugar and
some salt
oh my god it smells so good jeez
this looks like a beach when the wave
just
went away and your sand castle got
destroyed because you weren't paying
attention
and then your mom says it's time to go
home
you don't want to go home i don't know
where i was going with that
i found a little oven safe kind of
box there's a real name for this i don't
know what it's called so i'm going to
call it a white box
on a really big tray this is the biggest
tray that we have in the entire tasty
kitchen
as you can see we have lasagna noodles
molasses
i am going to try and create a foil wall
reminiscent of the foil wall i made in a
100 layer lasagna video i made a while
back
i dropped out of engineering school so
let's see if i can still do this
it's actually true okay
hold on oh boy
and this goes down one
two three four
five six six by four
that's thick the molasses is basically
an edible glue
one two three four five six
a little break four okay i hope this
works
fold over the edges
and where are you
good catch alvin to make sure that the
cheesecake doesn't stick i'm going to
line this with parchment paper
call me bob ross like that
that's half i'm gonna make another half
oh boy please don't break
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
one second oh there we go
okay looks like that 75
of an engineering degree is starting to
show
because this structure is 75 complete
and 75 stable okay
we're just gonna do that and then i'm
gonna use this to smooth it out
asmr
[Music]
this is like a zen garden but you can
eat it
this is taking a little longer than i
expected
this crust is done nice and compact time
to go
bake this big boy
please fit it's gonna bake for
until it's ready so until then
i think it's time to make the batter
okay we have a lot of stuff on the table
so the first thing that we're gonna do
is dump in a lot of cream cheese
everything on the table
may seem like a lot of stuff the thing
is
this is only a quarter of the batter
ingredients this bowl is the biggest
bowl we have and this is the maximum
amount of batter that we can make
at any given time oh yeah there we go
i want to be here for a while
okay that is like a cream cheese
landscape up next
sour cream and heavy cream back at it
don't spill cream everywhere alvin that
would be bad
getting a little bit of a workout doing
all this scrape down the sides
flowers next don't go everywhere
okay last
the eggs a little bit
of vanilla and lemon zest it's time to
go further beyond
maximum speed i can smell
burning coming from the machine i'm
pretty sure
it wasn't supposed to be left on this
long
all right i think this is pretty much
done batter is nice and smooth
i have to do three more of these oh my
god the crust is done
oh wow it smells so good oh
some of the molasses even dripped down
and caramelized that's really pretty
let's bring this back carefully
oh boy let's get you down there
it has been a very long time in the back
kitchen i had some culinary help
we have 20 liters of cheesecake batter
i just want to read to you guys the
recipe there are 10 cups of sugar
50 tablespoons of butter 320 ounces of
cream cheese which is a 40 philadelphia
blocks
5 cups of heavy cream 10 cups of sour
cream and 3 cups of flour
pinch of kosher salt 10 teaspoons of
vanilla extract
40 eggs and the zest of four lemons
now as my dad used to say that's a lot
of stuff
that was satisfying
[Music]
i'm having so much fun that's like one
whole cheesecake just went in right
there
i think this recipe is like 10 or 15
times an actual
cheesecake all right you know what let's
dump it
now that's nice get in there
all right
nothing happened that was definitely not
one of the walls breaking
oh my god lift with your legs not your
back
yeah don't break don't break
don't break i can hear the wall
straining under the weight
oh sh it's spilling
all right it's spilling a little bit in
the back so i'm going to evacuate it
as fast as i can i'm going to call for
some backup
okay so i put this guy on a cart
being very careful not to do
anything bad to it the tricky part is
gonna be how to get this guy
into the oven hip may request some
assistance
absolutely okay hip is one of the people
that makes this show happen all right on
three we're gonna lift
one two three okay
wow how amazing holy moly that was hard
thanks hip no problem okay so this guy's
gonna bake for probably like four hours
goodbye dude so to make the glaze for
the strawberry topping
let's start with some corn starch this
is some nice cranberry and
strawberry juice it helps thicken the
glaze
and the rest of the juice goes in here
and with some sugar
okay the juice is boiling gonna
slowly add this cornstarch thing and
then you gotta stir
constantly oh that got thick
mega quick i'ma turn you off wow
transform into like a gel in like three
seconds
look at that and then to give it some
extra shine
a little bit of corn syrup i know it's
not the best thing in the world but hey
it makes things shiny so we have a
little bit more strawberries and a lot
more glaze
then we started with thanks to some help
and work with the culinary team in the
back
i don't know how many pints it is it was
like
a lot oh
that one's for me please stay
no stop dropping food on the floor you
dummy
i don't think we're going to need all of
it i do want to glaze these
nicely slowly
gently hello
this is the big cheesecake as you can
see he's been chilling
resting let's see what we got
that's a big boy i can't even move it
let's trim this guy
this is a very soft and tender
cheesecake that is one nice cross
section
stay
cover up all the cracks
holy [ __ ] that looks dope on the wide
angle
that's so wild all right i think this is
it
this is the giant cheesecake with a
strawberry topping it is probably 50 to
60 pounds at this point but i'm very
happy
i have a friend her name is hannah she
really likes cheesecake
i think it'll be fun to facetime her and
see what she thinks of this
hi alvin how are you good yeah we're on
set
you are someone who has made a lot of
cheesecake videos
on tasty i remember every time we'd have
meetings with the team
we refer to hannah as like the
cheesecake queen there's not a single
day
that goes by that i don't want to eat
cheesecake so
today we made actually you know what
i'm just gonna show you so excited oh my
gosh one
two three
alvin holy moly
alvin it's gorgeous well i'm glad you
like it how many packages of cream
cheese i
have often have you know those
philadelphia ones right the eight ounce
ones we use 40 of them
every time i think you're like done
surprising me you come up with something
else
this is incredible she's pink queen
approved
that's what we wanted
wow it's bending the knife all right
look at that yeah this cheesecake
probably feeds a family of four
in the finish some piping art ta-da
one slice of the cheesecake
time to eat that's nice
[Music]
whoa it almost tastes better than the
regular cheesecakes i made
soft fluffy crust is nice very happy
with this result so you guys are
probably wondering at this point
what is going to happen with all of this
cheesecake
i really wanted to share this and give
this to my friends and people that i
admire
just like i normally would but in
current circumstances that really isn't
possible
so if you excuse me i have a lot of
cheesecake to consume
that's really good next up is the mac
and cheese
so for this episode one of the most
interesting parts
is we make the pasta noodles and we make
the pasta noodles
we made so many that it took me
and the culinary team two full days to
freshly make all those bow ties so when
you see
those big bow tie custom pastas on
screen
just let you know that we worked really
hard to make those and that took
forever there's smoke coming out of the
kitchenaid i'm getting a little bit of a
workout here
it's so long it's like cutting into a
dough pillow
[Music]
okay
hey guys i'm alvin welcome back to
tasties making it big
where we make huge versions of some of
america's most beloved foods
things have changed a little bit we're
in a different time different place
different circumstances but
one thing that hasn't changed is tasty's
love for giant foods today
we are gonna be making a huge mac and
cheese why
i love mac and cheese i love the pasta i
love the amount of cheese that goes into
it i think it's delicious and i think
it's gonna be really fun
just make a giant version of it so let's
get started
okay so for mac and cheese the first
thing i want to do is make
fresh pasta all right i have my uh
trusty friend here
i'm gonna go in with i should have put
it in the bowl first but that's okay
and about one two three four five six
seven
a lot of eggs and some salt and instead
of doing this all by hand
like a true pasta maker would i'm gonna
use the power of technology with my
friend todd here
oh that's spilled flour everywhere yet
todd's just going to do his thing for
the next five ten minutes or so and
hopefully doesn't get too tired out but
i'm just gonna sit back and wash while
he does all the work so
see you guys in a little bit
there's smoke coming out of the
kitchenaid i don't know if you can tell
but i think you might have overworked
todd a little too hard
thanks dude you've done good today
served your purpose
we could take it to the the kitchenaid
graveyard
sad music place
pouring out for the homie todd
i would say todd probably got me eighty
ninety 90
of the way there it's up to me to carry
the burden to finish the rest
it's look kind of not as smooth as i
would have liked
but to be honest guys i'm kind of weak
right now i haven't gone in the gym in a
very long time i'm just gonna let this
rest hopefully
the resting relaxes the dough all right
we're gonna
get you in here good job dude time for
this guy to take a nap
[Music]
okay so i made two more doughs while the
first one is resting
all right you had a nap come out now
shape them up a little bit okay i want
to cut this guy into eight pieces so
that's
four and then two good math alvin
[Music]
oh that's satisfying like cutting into a
dough pillow this will be over here
it's like a scone this is pretty cool
all right let's get
this guy into a rough shape for the
pasta machine table is shaking
that's okay i'm gonna roll it in this
pasta machine
just to make sure that we're good and
the handle
came out that's fine can we go in
already yes we can
come on you can do it yeah
not bad for one we're gonna do one more
i think you're making a couple of fun
pasta shapes and
she's a ruler and seven inches by four
inches
should be good the handle really just
doesn't like being in the pasta machine
today give it a nice flare
now it's looking good okay so i'm
actually gonna make
little bow ties i don't know i really
like the bow tie shape
little bow tie or a big bow tie i guess
when i keep making these bow ties for a
while
until i have a lot excuse me while i
spend some private time making
this pasta okay pasta is all done
uh time to make the cheese sauce first
we're gonna start with four sticks of
butter
a lot of butter this is gonna be kind of
like not really a bechamel but a cheese
sauce that involves
making a roux first so i'm gonna get
this butter melted that'd take a while
okay so the butter is melted time for
the flour
that's a lot of flour usually you know
rose like one tablespoon of flour to one
tablespoon of butter we put like four
sticks of butter that's
32 times what a usual amount for this
kind of thing would be
i think it's time to season this so we
have garlic powder onion powder
pepper mustard powder salt and some
paprika season your stuff kids
makes a big difference add some milk oh
that's a spill
you gotta whisk really hard no lumps
i'm getting a little bit of a workout
here oh okay it's getting thick
more milk i don't think i've ever made
this much sauce before it's kind of cool
and the funny thing is that this isn't
even all the sauce
i'm gonna have to do this again because
this is the biggest pot that we can cook
it in so the actual amount of sauce is
going to be double
what we have here final batch
please fit okay there's a lot of sauce
it's gonna take a long time to cook
so i'm gonna put a lid on it and i'm
gonna let this guy hang out and cook
with the lid cracked see you in a bit
please
okay it's been a while and it's been
boiling and it got really thick and nice
which is fantastic
and now probably one of my favorite
parts about making cheese sauce
is the cheese so i want to take this off
the heat shredded
cheddar a lot of it
i want to take this slow it smells
amazing
let's get the rest of it in there please
be enough room
cheese you melt right once you melt well
the volume disappears that's how science
works
right wow this is wild i'm gonna
go back to the whisk slow and steady
wins the race
is what a loser would say but in this
case
they're correct i think we are pretty
much
there i do want to taste it though
[Music]
that's so good we'll be right back
i'm gonna go cook some noodles
okay so we are back in the tasty kitchen
and we have a huge pot of water boiling
all of our bow ties have been made have
been drying over here so i think
it's time to give them a nice little hot
tub
boop go in make sure you don't stick
to the bottom put on one of these go to
the prom with a wedding it's pretty good
see you guys in a bit why babies hit
these big bow ties
okay so these guys have been in for
about 10 minutes now i think it's time
to come out
so we're gonna put them in some cold
water make sure they don't stick to each
other and dry out
here's guy number one
they've maintained the bow tie structure
which makes you really happy oh yeah i'm
gonna have to get out of here soon
my right arm might fall off all right
i have a whole lot more pasta to cook so
i'll be standing here
switching between my arms so they don't
fall off and after that
i think it's gonna be time to build the
mac and cheese so excuse me i have some
bow ties to cook
okay so i think we're ready to assemble
ton of pasta
lots and lots of cheese i think this is
like 10 liters
of a cheese sauce and i think the best
way to go about this is to
probably layer it to first start off i'm
going to get some of this
cheese sauce and lay it down no
questions about it
the cheesiest thing i've ever done
layered down some
noodles one
this might take a while okay and then
some more cheese sauce
let's get rid of this dude first some
cheddar
it's so fun and then a little bit of
matz oh
then another layer of pasta okay let's
do some more cheese
colby jack in there get some more
in this moths let's do some gouda like a
kid in a candy store
it's pretty good okay next layer
i got some on my neck hold on
i knew that was gonna happen then we
will do
some gruyere
wow that's a lot of cheese and the rest
of the gouda
there's just so much cheese this is the
size of the one that we made
and this is the size of a regular bow
tie it's probably like 20 times the size
let's knock out the cheddar on this
layer huh actually i'll save some of you
for the top
okay i think this might be the final
layer wow there's still a lot of stuff
in there
last bit cheesy saucy goodness
smooth it out hold those cracks and last
but not least
some fresh mozzarella for that nice
cheesiness
i might have put too much cheese or
maybe there's no such thing you know put
some browning on top
last bit of cheddar i think that's it
i don't really know how heavy this is
okay i want to put this on a cart and
we're gonna go bake this
all right come on little dude it's time
to go in the oven
i feel like i'm dragging my kid to
school
i don't have any kids but if i did this
is how i would drag them
maybe i shouldn't say that let's get you
into the oven little boy
oh that sounded weird
[Music]
all right wow it's like bending the rack
okay goodbye dude
see this guy probably bake for at least
an hour or so
but yeah the cheese is getting
really melty as you can see and to make
sure that this cheese gets a nice and
bubbly top we're going to
broil it i'll babysit it make sure that
doesn't burn and we'll see how it goes
oh boy oh wow this is
this looks amazing
this is a big one
oh school's over i'm dragging my kid
back home
come on little guy let's go
so we're back the cheese is here it
smells amazing and the finish i want to
garnish with
sprinkle of chives whoa that makes it
look very expensive
also adds a nice sort of oniony taste to
the cheese which will be really good
okay this is the moment of the troop the
big big cheese pull there's no time
like now for a cheese pull alvinzo 20
20.
oh man oh man
look at this beautiful deliciousness
ready for it i think it's it's a little
hot
okay let's go with the ladle screw this
little spoon
this is gonna be a huge scoop
oh yeah
all right let's give myself some mac and
cheese
okay that's pretty good finish it off
i'm really excited to eat this i think
it's gonna be awesome yeah i'm just
gonna eat so you guys
have to watch me do that
oh man that was so good oh my god
it's creamy it's cheesy super seasoned
well wow i'm gonna eat a lot of this
okay so you guys are probably wondering
what's gonna happen with all this mac
and cheese
to be honest i would have loved to share
this with friends and other people
because i just like feeding them food
unfortunately that's just not something
i can do right now and i'm just really
glad that i'm not lactose intolerant so
if excuse me
i have a lot of mac and cheese to
consume i'm boba this is probably my
favorite episode of the season
the scariest part was when i was pouring
all the boba in
and all that liquid was so hot the glass
was steaming up and i needed to put milk
and ice inside of it because that's how
bubba is but i was so
scared there like 15 people watching
that if i poured that ice in too quick
the whole thing was gonna shatter
it's gonna break start the last one in
my head i was like no
i'm not putting ice because i put ice in
that would have shattered
would have been a bad time and if you're
really careful you can see
how nervous i am during those moments we
tried to cut it out but
yeah i was mortified so why look out for
that part because
i was freaking out hi i'm alvin welcome
back to tasty's making it big where we
make
giant versions of some of america's most
beloved foods
today i'm gonna be making a giant boba
milk tea drink but the thing is i've
never made boba from scratch
so i'm gonna call my friend inka she was
my co-host on the giant ramen episode
and i think it's gonna be a lot of fun
so
enough talk and let's get started
what's up inka how's it going alvin good
we are using
your bubble recipe today to make a giant
boba i'm going to get started so
first thing is the the sugar in the
water right okay stir it until it gets
dissolved right
yep wait what heat should i be cooking
this on basically just enough for the
sugar to melt
you don't want it to be on high heat do
you have it on high heat that was on
height
yikes yeah basically once it's warm
you'll want to remove it from the heat
actually or remove it
sorry table that one tablespoon full
that's a lot that's a little bit a
little bit less okay it's like that
yeah sure all right she said it so if
the recipe goes wrong
it's not my fault you know i can only
see so much from the zoom
oh that's true it's 100 my fault as
you're stirring it right
it should form into like almost like a
paste that's great
once it's all dissolved you want to
return it to the heat and now you just
cook it down
until it's slightly thicker okay return
to the heat wow it's like three
ingredients but
the amount of like technique is quite a
lot i think it's getting kind of
thick now the rest of this starch goes
in and then stir fast
oh it's getting sticky oh boy like
really lumpy
it's like really hard to scrape off the
bottom of the pan yo how do i know when
to
get it out you're supposed to get it out
like asap but
oh okay asap all right so far
things are going bad
dude that's really liquidy this is your
recipe yo
but can you work with this do you think
so i think so i can't feel it so
yeah i mean it feels like oh god okay it
looks really weird right now so i'm not
gonna
i don't know how to describe this
texture uh
uh it's a little sticky and it's kind of
warm
what the heck it's kind of like alive
the moment you set it down
it like does its own thing but when you
try to move it it's like a rock
wait okay then i think there's something
wrong
what's wrong it's not supposed to be
like a rock
yo i don't think that's right when
you're putting the starch in it
remember how like for you it was just
like a liquid it's supposed to be
like a dough at that point already yeah
no like it comes right off right that's
not right
when you pull it it should be stretchy
at this point stretchy
i think we have to redo it alvin oh no
it's 100
my fault it's okay it's only a few
ingredients it'll be okay
we'll be right back uh attempt number
two
you were saying that i messed up in the
sauce like the thick sauce stage we
think that's what it is that you need to
get it to a consistency of a thick mochi
sauce and hopefully
that's the problem thick mochi sauce
thick mochi sauce thick mochi sauce
can you see this is that almost there
right no
it's not oh keep going ah that's where
that was the issue i think the first
time i didn't make the thick mochi sauce
it was just
sauce oh yeah i think it's good
are you 100 sure i'll take the blame you
can i'm like
85 80. oh that's a b
75 okay let's add the start okay off
heat right
yeah okay are you worried oh a hundred
percent
let's go for it okay she said go for it
please work does it feel different oh it
feels so different oh my god
like nothing's really getting stuck yes
yes yes yes yeah
so now what you have to do is roll it
out a little bit into like an
oval shape divide it into three sections
okay you need to wrap plastic around two
of the doughs this is just to help
retain its
moisture okay what's next what's next
roll this one out
into like a long snake shape until it's
like
roughly around 0.5 you have a ruler with
you
yeah i do 0.5 is actually still too big
it should be a little smaller
like a finger like a finger okay yeah
look at that little ball oh that looks
so nice
yes looks great
boba has a pretty unique texture when
cooked how do you describe what it
tastes like or feels like
well the taste is faintly sweet but the
texture
is q-q q-q so kiki is the term that
people in taiwan use to describe the
texture when it's kind of chewy it has a
slight bounce to it but it's not rubbery
i feel like there's a misconception
there
mochi is kind of q-q you know like it's
that kind of a situation and qq is my
favorite word to describe everything
noodles can also be qq when they're
cooked
right i have currently rolled only this
much
yeah oh my god thanks nina for helping
me good luck alvin i'm sorry i can't be
there to help
i have a lot of work to do i'm going to
be here for like hours do
jesus okay we're back in the tasty
kitchen with a huge pot
of boiling water for the tea these are
black tea bags these are the ones that i
use and i used to make and sell bubble
milk tea i'll tell you guys that story
later
but essentially you would just take
these tea bags and drop it in
and we have 500 tea bags
sounds like a lot that's because it is i
think this might have enough caffeine
to keep an elephant going for a very
very long time
all right so this is all the tea it's
been chilled it's been brewed
as you can tell the color is super
intense it gets like
22 liters or so i don't know how many
cups of boba that's gonna make but i
think the answer is
a lot
okay after many hours and some culinary
assistance we were able to make
a lot of fresh bobas four trays probably
like a thousand
of these little ones all right here we
go oh they're like little
little bullets oh wow this is really hot
all right let's give these a stir one
more
here we go oh this is burning don't kill
yourself alvin
come on that was pretty dense in inka's
recipe the goal is to cook these until
the bubbles rise to the surface
goodbye you little boba balls whoa whoa
all these little bobas they're nice and
plump
so i'm going to take these guys directly
into some ice water anka said this stuff
is really important because it sort of
shocks the outside
of the boba and helps to give it that qq
texture that she was talking about
they look really good and they can't
stay in the ice water for too long
wow look at that that's awesome
okay i have a lot of little boba balls
to cook so
see you guys in a bit pretty important
part
about boba at least for me is if it has
like a nice brown sugar syrup and to
start five cups of water into this giant
pot
and seven and a half cups of dark brown
sugar
stir this until everything comes
together you sort of have
this syrupy brown sugar that's really
nice and i've coats the outside
of the cup and they kind of make this
streaky pattern probably my favorite
part
is going to be cooking the boba in it so
here we go
stir until it gets nice and sticky
and sugary and delicious oh my god it
smells
oh it smells amazing i do want to taste
one
oh oh that's good all right i'm gonna
let this cool down
and then we're gonna go build the boba
drink woohoo
okay so i found a vase that's apparently
supposed to be used in hotel lobbies
around the world
as my boba glass it is 10 inches by 30
inches tall which
in mathematical sense means it's very
big
no alvin there's no pressure you just
can't do it again if you mess it up
let's first get the boba in oh my god
there is a
don't break there is a huge vertical
distance that this is going to have to
travel
probably going to spill everywhere but
that's okay this is really hot
oh wow it's like steaming the glass up
yeah you know we don't we don't gotta
use the sound for that right we could
just tweak it we could skip past
that part that's fine my dream was to
have the whole thing a hundred percent
fresh food
but i unfortunately don't have the
manpower and miscalculated a lot of this
so i asked our culinary team to get some
of the fast quick boba
i still wanted it to have the look of a
real boba milk tea so in this boba there
is a mix
it's not all fresh but i still think
it's gonna taste great so please don't
be too mean to me in the comments
but that's what we ended up doing at the
shops they kind of get the brown sugar
drizzle going down the sides
kind of want to emulate that so we're
gonna
that's a spill we're gonna do this
wow this sound is really something else
huh okay it looks kind of cool
i'm pretty into it oh i was gonna tell
you guys a story about how i used to
sell boba back in the day
i was a junior high school kid after
lunch we'd always go get boba
so i thought i could make a lot of money
by also doing it so i dropped out of
chinese school
much to the dismay of my mother figured
out how to make boba at home
went to costco got the big cups the
recipe was exactly the same as this tea
i set up a little table outside a
classroom when the bell rang
the kids came out i sold it for 250
without boba three dollars with boba
the kids would buy it made a couple
hundred dollars that summer
when i ran out of boba my mom would
actually stay at home to cook the boba
and drive over a couple of batches
whenever i ran out but in return
she asked for 50 of all proceeds
i was like mom that's a lot of money and
she was like alvin i'm just trying to
teach you
this is how life works she told me that
she was actually going to save the 50
and put in my bank account later i never
saw that money ever in my life again
she denies all allegations and has no
recollections of the final amount of
money i had if you're watching mom
all my money back yo you can't make milk
tea
without milk so thanks cows
[Music]
look at that
that was pretty cool this is bigger than
my wildest dreams
please hold don't break
so uh i'm couldn't find a straw that was
big enough on amazon so i ended up
ordering a clear pvc pipe
i think this is the only thing that will
be usable for
this boba i'll be very careful with this
but here we go
get in there oh it went to the bottom
now
we are going to slowly stir
is it moving i can't tell this
is actually really hard oh my god this
camera is pissing me off up here
slow this is wild oh my god my shoulders
are so tired
[Music]
okay i think that's all the steering i
can do wow this is the complete finish
thing
this is a lot of bubble i don't even
know how much this weighs i'll have to
do some math later but
i do want my friend hinka to see the
final result so i'm gonna give her a
call
and just show her what we got what's up
how's it going you want to see the giant
boba that we made
yes show me all right one
two three oh
my god wait is that a straw it's a pvc
pipe
oh my god this is insane that's so much
tea and so much boba
yeah it's uh six gallons of milk uh
22 liters of black tea this is crazy i
love it
congratulations you did it you made it a
giant boba tea
i mean this is your recipe just times
500 probably
enjoy all right
[Music]
wow this tastes really good i think this
is definitely something you could serve
at a boba shop and people would buy it
so you guys are probably wondering
what's gonna happen with all that boba
i would have loved to share it with my
friends people that i like to see just
because that's something i like to do
with the show but unfortunately that's
just not something i'm able to do right
now
so if excuse me i have a lot of things
to drink i had a lot of fun today and
i hope you guys had fun watching so i'll
see you guys next time
so chicken parm stuffed garlic bread
this is actually one of my classic tasty
videos i made
a long time ago fun fact when i super
sized it i had to re-watch
my video three times because i forgot
how i actually did it in the initial
video which sounds weird because i was
the one that made the initial tc video
but
flashing back looking at that video i
was like man
i've changed a lot since then and i'm
pretty happy that things are now for the
better
and just very excited for this episode a
lot of fun call backs and references but
yeah it really got me thinking to the
time when uh i was making old tv videos
so yeah
enjoy the episode will you come out he's
having a hard time letting go
it kind of feels like i'm making mochi
get ready for the burial
[Music]
listen
hey i'm alvin welcome back to tasties
making bake the show where i make
giant versions of some of america's most
beloved foods
and fun of fact this year is tasty's
fifth anniversary it's been
five years since we've started this
crazy food adventure and to celebrate
i'm gonna be making a
giant chicken parmesan stuffed garlic
bread which is a video that i made a
while back i think it's gonna be a lot
of fun so
let's get started okay so to start i'm
gonna make
the giant garlic bread from scratch and
that means
making fresh bread as you guys can see
this is a starter
he's been starting for 24 hours now
usually people name their starter
i think i might get too emotionally
attached if i do so i'm just gonna
he's gonna just nameless here and to
start off i'm going to mix the yeast
with the water
yeast needs time to get bubbly and it'll
do its thing over there and into this
big bowl
i got the flour and some salt i'm just
gonna
mix this guy up he's getting gassy okay
let's
hop this guy open oh that smell is
definitely something
come on get out of your little box look
at that
all right can you come out like this
will you come out oh he's coming out
he's having a hard time letting go
that's okay we all do sometimes all
right
this guy's all done okay so now i'm
gonna mix
this with the flour you know what i'm
just gonna use my hands for a little bit
this is quite soft it kind of feels like
i'm making mochi
the goal is to get kind of a shaggy
dough
getting flour everywhere i think this
guy is pretty much ready to go in
all that yeast look at those bubbles
start to get that incorporated
this might take me a while i'll be right
back okay
so it's like kind of coming together
it's like a sticky shaggy mass
and because this is tasty's fifth
birthday episode
i thought i might share a couple stories
from what it was like
you know being here since the beginning
so fun fact this chicken parmesan garlic
bread video
i made it a long time ago and it was
actually just me
in here on like a sunday night i was
like ah this is just another tasty video
and then i just made it didn't think
much of it i did pretty well and
now i guess i realize all my best ideas
come to me on the weekends
when i'm not working is that weird or is
that normal i think this
is kind of there this is gonna be kind
of messy
are you gonna come out please come out
okay
that's i probably could have done a
better job of that this is not
too far away from the course i feel a
little bit better about that now
it's very sticky you know
i think i'm gonna wash my hands i'm
gonna wrap saran wrap around this
let it proof for 45 minutes and clean up
this entire
table because i am a mess oh look
tasty's fifth birthday
whoa so this guy has been
proofing for like 45 minutes it's time
to punch some of the air out which is
always pretty fun because
i like punching things oh uh i'm not
aggressive
i promise at this stage the top is ugly
so this is the fold step so back to more
reminiscing about tasty
we started to explore more cinematic
videos on youtube
and one of the ones that i've been most
proud to work on is a video called the
magic of bread making
where this french baker goose
owns a little bakery in brooklyn called
lip primary and i remember editing the
sequence where he was folding the dough
and i remember that being some of the
most satisfying shots i've ever seen
even though i'm not as good as he is
this part definitely
reminds me of him go check it out so
once you got all those ugly little bits
kind of shambled together you get to go
underneath and flip the whole thing
big baby look at that
now that he has been folded and shaped a
little bit better it's like a butt
very firm went to the never mind um go
to sleep dude
okay so while the bread finishes
proofing i'm gonna fry the chicken
in the original video it's a chicken
breast that is you know cut up into
small pieces
breaded and then fried since we're
making it big we're not gonna cut up the
chicken we're gonna use the whole
chicken breast salt some pepper
but you can't just put only salt and
pepper on chicken come on guys
like uh onion powder garlic powder
paprika
seasoned chicken should basically be a
different color to all those crevices
there you go see now the chicken doesn't
look like chicken anymore that's when
you know it's been seasoned correctly
trying to get all the seasoning off of
the pan the chicken has been properly
seasoned so we're breading it with the
flour the eggs and the bread crumb
pretty classic setup just like we did
in the original tasty video shake off
the excess flour
into the egg same with you and we'll
flip into the bread crumbs
and we're gonna cover it completely make
sure that we can get
all the good parts covered let's put
them over here to rest while do the
other dude get ready for the
burial this runs you in the time my
friends buried me in the sand one time
at the beach
and then they forgot about me all right
alvin be careful
ooh i think that'll pull a little too
much but that's fine if you're at home
don't do what i just did be a little
savory don't put in two at the same time
i got a little excited but you don't
want the oil to be too
close to the top the goal is just to get
a good looking shell on the top it's a
little crispy
that's all good nice drain over here
this guy and drain over here i'm going
to bread and fry the other two these
aren't fully cooked the outside is so
once i finish frying all four of these
i'm going to put them in the oven
just to finish cooking all the way
through excuse me i have some more
chicken to fry
so this guy has been proofing for
another 45 minutes
and he has gotten quite a large i'm
gonna do the
whoosh oh that was less dramatic than i
thought oh baby look at that
okay let's press into it get all those
little bubbles out wow you can hear the
gas coming out
and then fold the top third over down
and then
seal it in the bottom third over seal
to make sure that this gets a nice
oblong shape and repeat that
kind of like a nice yule log just
kidding i don't know how you logs are
made
so we're gonna go and roll it's very fun
to play with
kind of reminds me of the giant donut
episode that i did for making it big
that was not that great but that's okay
this is a very large reptile this is the
biggest bread we can make because this
is the biggest tray that can fit in the
oven that we have
so i'm gonna let this guy proof for
another 45 minutes
until he gets bigger one last time and
then he's gonna go into the oven
so throw up my dude
okay so the chick is all cooked and you
can't have garlic bread without garlic
butter so
i'm just gonna make a lot of garlic
butter which we'll start with
who is butter who knew the amount of
times
i've made garlic butter for a tasty
video is
probably in upwards of like 50 back in
the day when i was coming up with a lot
of these recipe
video ideas i would almost have this
weird spreadsheet thing where i had a
column
of like popular food items and terms
like garlic butter chicken
steak mozzarella sticks onion rings all
those things and on the other side i
would have another
20 and i would almost play this mix and
match game where i would like try to
combine two random phrases to see
if they work chicken parmesan and garlic
bread actually came out of those two
okay so the butter is frothing
time for the garlic just to get the
aromas going i've made this so many
times but it always smells amazing
oh man all right so i'm going to take
this guy off the heat
yeah i don't want to get too much color
on it because we're still going to put
it in the oven later
i'm going to add some parsley this is a
good old tasty garlic butter recipe
okay so i think the bread looks pretty
much ready so i
think it's time to roll out and bake
this giant
loaf of bread for this chocolate bread
so that way this garlic butter has a
home
so wow smells amazing
this is the final look of the bread
before he goes into the oven i'm gonna
score the top
one two three four five
and six i'm going to bring him to the
oven
let's go come on vamanos everybody let's
go this is a heavy boy
well hey look you jiggle too much
sparta
all right here you go big buddy
all right goodbye dude
see you until you're big again
okay so this is how the bread came out
it is a beautiful
looking and smelling loaf
very proud of it he grew up to become a
very fine
red boy there little buddy
in the original video the normal sized
bread is cut into sections and hollowed
out so i'm going to be doing that but on
a very large scale there's a scene
ratatouille where chef colette says you
can tell
a loaf of bread is good not by the smell
but by
the sound hopefully this bread is good
oh yeah that's a good bread listen
music to my ears sorry i had a lot of
fun doing that
and the next step is to hollow it out
just like in the video to make room for
the chicken
there really is nothing quite like
freshly baked bread oh it's hot
look at that it's wow this is steamy you
can see
that's one i'm watching you that's kind
of scary don't do that
oh this bread is so good oh it smells
amazing
i want to do these for the rest of these
pieces i'll be right back okay so all of
these
have been hollowed out you can tell and
i'm going to
start the chicken stuffing process
putting a whole
chicken breast in here so let's see how
we're going to do this
and just start stacking wow this is
gonna be one tasty meal
see all those gaps that's gotta be
filled with the cheese
let's do another one let's trim off a
little bit that's fine
please fit that's a tight fit yeah
vertical might be the way to go
some cheese in there yep okay so every
single one of these pieces
has been stuffed with chicken and cheese
and just like the video
last part is to transfer them onto a
tray and brush them with garlic butter
to seal the ends
we got the tips make sure all the little
cracks and crevices
wrap them up and this guy is ready for
the oven
and this is where all the magic is gonna
happen so
off you go okay
here we go let's take this guy out let's
see
how are you doing big guy
whoa this is the good stuff okay come on
nice and we have uh some nice marinara
sauce here
to go with the garlic bread and just for
you guys a
nice big old cheese pull
oh hello there that's nice
okay i think it's time to eat all right
look at
this beautiful guy that is quite large
i have to knife and fork this guy oh
that's crispy
oh my god it smells so good geez i'm not
even kidding a little bit of sauce
whoa it tastes better than the video of
it i made a while ago that's crazy
i'm gonna keep eating this please excuse
me for a moment
okay so you guys are probably wondering
what's gonna happen with all this garlic
bread and all this chicken and
honestly you know i wanted to be able to
share this with friends and people that
i like to feed
but unfortunately that can happen this
time so if you excuse me
i have a lot of garlic bread and chicken
to consume
so i will see you guys
next time yay
cut the video okay giant hot dog so for
this episode the funniest part was
finding that big giant hot dog casing
because we were looking at it we googled
a salami wrapper we googled the hot dog
rapper we there was nothing
that big and then we had to like find a
company
that made giant mortadella and go on to
their restaurant shipping site and find
the specific largest sort by most
expensive casing that we could find it
was like 50 bucks for this big red
casing
so when we see how we made the hot dog
and how we encased it
just just say finding that thing was
very difficult
but i'm glad we did hello i'm alvin
welcome back to tasties making a big the
show where i make giant versions of some
of america's
most beloved foods today i'm going to be
making
a huge hot dog how are we going to do it
i'm not so sure yet but we're going to
find out right now
okay so you can't make a hot dog without
making a
hold on stop so you can't make a hot dog
without making a
hot dog so we're gonna make a hot dog we
have a kitchenaid mixer with a
meat grinder attachment all the parts
have been frozen to keep
everything nice and chilled if it warms
up things start to stick get messy and
that's not good
over here i have a lot of chuck which is
a nice cut of beef with a lot of fat and
flavor
i've never made a giant hot dog before
let alone a
regular hot dog so i'm going to make a
hot dog
make sure that this doesn't get stuck i
want to do one piece
at a time and you go
where'd you go dude i put him in but
he's not coming out
so we got to put in another one come on
man
slowly oh i can hear this guy working
really hard
if you remember my friend todd here from
the mac and cheese episode
had a little bit of a medical accident
where smoke was coming out
since then he's been a long time in the
er and he might be sent back to the
hospital in a little bit
all right now it's slowly working whoa
whoa whoa
calm down now so i figured out that
grinding of that beef would have taken
us probably like two days with that
you know old machine so i went out to
the store got some ground beef the
butchers are way better
than i am and doing that kind of stuff
because you know as a wise poet once
said
ain't nobody got time for that grinding
isn't enough hot dogs are smooth they're
not burgers
that requires some additional processing
oh
yeah look at this guy
and to turn the mixture into more of a
smooth emulsified paste
i'm adding a little bit of ice water to
help it maintain its structure
delicious i want to say this batch is
done for now see what we got wow that
really is
fresh hot dog stuff oh
that smell is something else i would
i would have processed the second batch
and you know y'all don't need any more
details about that i want to do that and
you guys just
just chill out for a couple seconds
there are certain seasonings that make
hot dogs taste like hot dog so
we have salt sugar garlic and onion
powder
dry marjoram dried coriander smoked
paprika
sweet paprika white pepper mustard
powder
mace the spice not the self-defense
weapon
and last sodium nitrate which is a
curing salt that gives the hot dog
its signature pink red color after it's
cooked
oh boy this is a lot of seasoning the
one thing i will say is that
it now smells a lot better so this
meat mixture has now been completely
seasoned we have a
large sausage casing that we purchased
from the bologna company
so i have a strong hunch so they know
what they're doing
in order for us to make a hot dog with
it it does need to hydrate a little bit
so i'm putting it in warm water so it
can become nice
and stretchy and flexible so we can put
the meat inside of it
and this will take about 30 minutes this
is really weird it's like a giant chili
pepper
how do you open this guy like like
no the goal is to get all of this meat
inside this casing this is going to be a
very weird process hold on
this kind of feels like when you're
filling up a pastry bag for like piping
frosting so
let's just think of it that way oh no
get you better not oh my god i swear to
god dude
are you kidding me you are kidding me
good thing this table is clean
okay so this is what it looks like when
all that meat
uh was put in the casing i'm gonna need
to tie it so i want to get a
nice twist going on see if i can tie
this guy
okay i think it's time to cook it good
job dude
we have a nice water bath to help it
cook slowly
and gently if i had kids this is how i
would lay them to sleep
not not in a water bath that's that's
that's that's bad
all right come on dude oh boy
[Music]
come on in you go this guy's in the oven
gonna cook for around two hours to
slowly
slowly cook it through the water bath
and then we'll check back
so our friend todd is back to make the
hot dog bun
from scratch so to start i'm combining
some
warm milk some sugar and the yeast so
that the yeast
has plenty of food this is a recipe that
is directly from
joshua weissman he has some great stuff
on youtube so be sure to check him out
because his recipes are really good
all right oh and i spilled classic
outfit okay
this is gonna chill out until it starts
to get nice and bubbly into the mixer
i'm adding some red flour don't spill
here i spilled
okay good enough and some salt just
gonna
incorporate this a little bit
todd has seen some stuff it took me a
while to coax him back out to come back
out for another round but
we're gonna get every ounce of power out
of this guy before he
needs to go to the scrap yard that's
kind of dark
[Music]
okay so the yeast has grown up a little
bit
as you can see this is pretty much ready
to go
it's coming together to make this dough
even richer and nicer i have two eggs
and two egg yolks that i'm just gonna
add
todd i'm sorry i'm gonna have to kick it
up a notch for you
[Music]
let's make the dough extra soft supple
and rich i'm gonna go slowly with a
couple of tablespoons of butter
this is where the real battle begins
hang in there i got four more
tablespoons of butter coming i can't
give out
quite yet keep going
never give up okay i think the dough is
done
all right take a long rest buddy
nice i'm gonna shape this guy into a
nice
pillowy ball this dough feels so nice
oh my god so it's been 45 minutes since
this bread has been resting
he's grown quite a lot as you can see
and this dough has so many air bubbles
it's so light it's super fluffy
so i'm going to punch it down wow that's
fun look at all that
gluten development that's what i'd like
to see
come on come on look at that
trying to shape it into a hot dog bun
shape so i'm
again sort of tucking and rolling
kind of looks like a baby i don't want
to name you though because
probably get attached and then i have to
like cut in half for the hot dog oh
name i'll just call you baby okay let's
put you in your little
foil crib i don't know how to hold
children
that's not how you should treat children
at all so this
is gonna proof for another 45 minutes or
so before it bakes and then right before
it bakes i'm gonna brush some egg
on top of it to give it some really nice
color into the oven you go big dude
goodbye
the hot dog's been cooked in that water
bath and
cooled that was fun that was like in
kindergarten
look at that it smells really good like
a really really seasoned
beef thing to get the really nice color
it deserves we're gonna help it by
making a little bit of a glaze
i'm gonna put in some barbecue sauce
some
ketchup and a little bit of oil
let's brush this dude time to paint
nice i'm bob ross i'm currently painting
with
a deep shade of hot dog red there are no
mistakes
just happy little accidents i'm very bad
at art
but i can brush hot dogs over soft buns
any day i'm going to put this into an
oven so that
the glaze can sort of caramelize and
cook and bind with the sausage
and i will be right back big boy
okay we have a wonderful hot dog-esque
giant tray
that was made by our art team i think
it's fantastic and this is what we're
gonna serve the hot dog
in first things first let's get the bun
in there
all we're gonna do is we're gonna split
the bun down the middle
don't mess this up alvin
slow and steady okay how am i gonna get
you
all the way in there guess we just gotta
go for it
houston we have landed that's not what
they say right houston
usually they say houston we have a
problem but there are no problems
in houston i mean new york can't have a
hot dog without ketchup
and mustard let's draw some squiggles
[Music]
i think that's okay so oh [ __ ]
maybe i should have done that
i think i did it looks like a dna helix
but that's okay
i think this is a giant hot dog i'm very
happy with it it's pretty heavy i want
to say like 20 pounds
this hot dog is the size and weight of
at least
80 hot dogs it looks pretty good time to
eat it
oh it's really soft and tender whoa
look at that wow look at that color
this is my portion a nice sausage meat
patty with two
nice bread croutons
that's a lot better than i thought it
was gonna be it still tastes like a hot
dog but it's like a fancy
sausage meatball thing to be fair
everything here was made from scratch
there's none of those preservatives
those artificial flavorings maybe that's
why it didn't taste as
nostalgic but i will say pretty darn
good hot dog
so you guys are probably wondering
what's gonna happen to the rest of this
i would have personally loved to share
this with friends because that's
something i like to do
but unfortunately i can't do that right
now so me and this hot dog
gonna spend some really good quality
time together and i will see you guys
next time
it's just you and me dude last but not
least
the giant chocolate chip cookie this is
a riff on
my personal chocolate chip cookie recipe
and i knew from the moment that i did
this episode i was like alvin you're
gonna be santa i don't know how
i don't know when i don't know why but
you're gonna meet santa so i asked her
production coordinator to run over to
michaels and see if she could find
a hatchimal she could find a beard she
was great she found it in 10 minutes
cutback was like alvin i got your hat i
got your beard i put it on
and well it's gonna be a very merry
christmas
wow this is so fun i feel rich don't
spill album
don't spill this one genius if i do say
so myself
it's only stupid if it doesn't work
[Music]
hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making big the show where i make
giant versions of some of america's most
beloved foods so today i'm going to be
making a huge
chocolate chip cookie let's get started
okay so uh the first thing to making
great cookies
is a lot of butter as you can see this
is
10 sticks of butter so this recipe is a
scaled version of one of my older tasty
recipes
of cookies and what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna brown the butter
one two eight nine ten okay and this is
going to take a while
to melt down if you'll excuse me i'm
gonna melt this butter for a little bit
wow this is so fun i feel rich
oh some of the little flavored brown
bits are starting to come up to the
surface
that's a good sign okay so i've turned
off the heat
and i think this is beautiful it's like
liquid gold
okay so this guy is gonna go off the
heat and it's time to make the rest of
the dough
so now it's time to make the dough i
found the largest
bowl that we could find in the tasty
kitchen and
yeah let's make some cookies first i
have a lot of brown sugar
a lot of white sugar for a lot of flavor
i like to add a lot of salt
just give this a mix break up all that
brown sugars
so this recipe is 10 times the size of
the normal batch of cookie dough which
makes
about like 12 cookies so this is gonna
be one very very large cookie
okay oh the wrong way now that it's
cooled off a bit my favorite part
brown butter
[Music]
smells ridiculous and back in look at
that
one of the biggest reasons why i really
like baking cookies
it's literally because of this part
where i get to smell the brown butter
and the sugar
there's a candle that smells like this i
would spend a lot of money
a lot of eggs and
quite a lot of vanilla extract here we
go
coming together it's gonna work out you
know
all right the texture we want is these
beautiful
silky gold ribbons time for the dry
ingredients
10 cups of flour a lot of baking soda
and back in we go
slow this time don't spill alvin don't
spill this one just do one of these
yeah that'll mix it in real good genius
if i do say so myself
it's only stupid if it doesn't work this
mixer really does have a mind of its own
okay i think the dough part is ready
but can't have chocolate chip cookies
without the chocolate so
i'm gonna go get lots and lots of
chocolate be right back
okay so i brought a lot of chocolate i
like to use both milk and dark chocolate
i'll start with the milk chocolate first
i'm going to chop these all up into
pretty large chunks oh yeah
that's what i'm talking about let's get
all this into the batter let's just
start cutting some dark chocolate
that's so satisfying wow
this is like 20 chocolate bars i believe
all right
i'm saving these two bars for decoration
so i'm going to mix
this wonderful chocolate into the dough
probably one of my favorite parts it's
like
like mixing a salad oh yeah
listen to that sound you know what
i'm gonna use my hands oh this feels so
nice
okay i think that's mixed time to figure
out how i'm gonna bake this guy let me
go check in the back to see what we have
okay i found this uh really big cake pan
that we have
in the tasty kitchen i think this will
be a perfect size got some parchment
strips to keep it
non-stick just spray it just to be sure
parchment sling technique go in there
have it in the pattern almost like a
clock okay
i think this pan is sufficiently lined
now the gotta get all this batter out of
there
come on whoa nice all right let's get
the rest of you
i'm gonna spread this out i'm gonna use
my hands
let's get you situated just in case we
didn't have
enough chocolate we're gonna put some
more chocolate i'll
go here you know is there really such
thing as too much chocolate
i don't think so two entire bars of
chocolate just for the topping
this guy is ready for the oven i am so
happy with what we have right now
oh we let's put you in the oven big guy
oh there's this is cookies like at least
50 chocolate which is a good thing
because when i
make cookies i get to control how much
chocolate goes in
all right let's bake you for probably
like an hour to 300 nice and low
to give the whole thing enough time to
cook
wow later dude
oh boy this is a this is a heavy one
wow so this is what the cookie looks
like after
one and a half hours of baking and a lot
of resting time so i could slowly cool
down i'm really proud of this and you
know you can't have
a giant cookie without big milk i am
also very excited because
i have a friend named lindsay who's
baked cookies and really likes making
cookies so i think it'd be really fun
facetime we're in to see what she thinks
of this let's get lindsay on the phone
what's up lindsay hi
how's it going good i'm mad i'm not
there to eat whatever you're making
i would have preferred if there are
other people to share it with lindsay
made a really cool video where she
challenged a lot of tasty producers to
bake things
and that was a really fun one because
you've made so many things that video
and
lindsay also happened to make my cookies
which was really fun i actually baked
your cookies a lot for jasmine because
she's obsessed
with that all right well do you want to
see it i'm ready ready
one two three
alvin is a cake milk
you made it so beautiful thanks it's a
16 inch
cake pan the largest we could find at
the store this is a vase
i think i guess that's the next step for
me i guess it's just to go bigger that's
right go big or go home that's the motto
of the show
all right well thanks lindsay i'll see
you soon all right good luck
all right bye so it happens to be
almost christmas and milk and cookies
are a family tradition at least for me
around that time i leave them out for
santa so i thought it would be fun to
see if we can tempt
santa claus to come in hopefully we get
some never before seen footage of the
ever elusive
santa claus
[Music]
merry christmas oh what is this
it seems to be a large cookie
and milk usually when kids leave it out
for me it's not this big whoever made
this must be a
fine lad i will bring him many presents
no one seems to be watching i see no
reason not to try
my oh my this is quite the large cookie
look at this texture there's so much
chocolate and cookie
i think i will have myself a bite
usually everybody says
where is santa but no one asks how is
santa
the biggest problem of having this beard
is that i
hard to put food in my mouth hole
[Music]
rudolph this is a good cookie this may
be the best cookie i've had in all my
years i think i shall take
this cookie and hightail it back to the
north pole
oh sweet sugar plum i'm out of here
well if you made it to this part of the
video thank you for sticking around
thank you for supporting the show
supporting me watching and enjoying me
do all my little shenanigans that i do
throughout the show
[Music]
peace
[Music]